aujourd'hui hannibal c'est manu dibango
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout
durée de vie
ne pas
je
[Musique]
Je suis plus bologne aujourd'hui allons-y
Bonjour
reine des grottes avec une brigade
galapagos et plus de boba en afrique
c'est pourquoi les téléviseurs
[Musique]
oh
bien bien
[Musique]
deux
pas plus
de l'émetteur
quelconque
Oui
[Musique]
Merde
bien très mal
[Musique]
où
dans la tête
la
[Musique]
huelva
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ne va pas avec lui et s'ils t'appellent c'est digne de
des choses et à propos de ça
plein d'esprit à nouveau par l'action
Maisons
[Musique]
comment un verre de plus accuse l'odeur de l'empreinte
ne pas
ou non
[Musique]
avec plus de caoutchouc avec un peu plus